[Music]
very happy I know it was so terrible
over the last five weeks like my family
and friends were like tell me tell me
I'm like I can't wait you didn't even
tell your family your friends nobody I
didn't I wanted to keep them in suspense
and you know not ruin the first episode
for them I've gone through probably 25
boxes really you though do usually we do
like they're shooting an episode right
now and I read the script and I like
hyperventilated I know that sounds
ridiculous what I should expect it at
this point but I literally had to text
Dan our Creator and was like people
aren't gonna be ready for this cuz I'm
not ready for that how do you get
through table read day I mean is that
like is everybody just a mess you know
we because of the shooting schedule we
haven't had a table read in a long time
but when we did have table reads yeah I
remember that fifth episode like Chrissy
and I were both like just like tears
streaming down ER like everybody was
crying my water just broke
yep yeah with the chemistry between you
and my low immediate he's such a special
guy it's really not hard to have to just
love him I feel very safe I feel very
like protected with him I've never
really felt that with somebody that I've
worked with before so I feel incredibly
lucky everyday just to have this job but
then to get to work with him too it's
like I know I'm in good hands
[Music]
you